the cameras have been turned off
but the government can't tune out matt
hancock's affair
leaves several unanswered questions
firstly how were the pictures from
inside his office leaked outside
and are they from cctv or an
unauthorized device
security cameras watch the whole of
westminster
but who can access the images my
understanding in this case was that this
was a cctv camera operated by the
department of health
which is why it is being investigated by
the department of health
um we do not believe there is covert uh
concerns at this moment
um but there is an ongoing investigation
into this which
unfortunately uh we're going to have to
be patient on and wait for the details
of
but a more difficult question surrounds
the appointment of gina colladangelo
she was a paid non-executive director at
the department of health
personal relationships must be declared
and some
want regulation and a rethink over the
recruitment of friends
how is it that somebody who is a a
communication specialist for oliver
bonus
is judge suitable to be giving advice
to the secretary of state and others
about how to run his department
i mean at best this is he's appointing a
yes woman a woman
who was at university with a really old
chum you know at worst this is getting
his mistress to come
in and mark his own homework and then
there's the issue of matt hancock's
private email account
he used gmail for government business
the information commissioner
is looking into this it follows a number
of complaints
when we've got a big inquiry happening
on the pandemic we'll want to know that
all of the information is there
so it's hard to be sure therefore that
you know ministers are handing over all
the right information they're not
deleting
um anything that's you know particularly
sensitive or
personally awkward for them it all feels
awkward for matt hancock
the cameras aren't rolling but the
debate over his relationship
runs on not just about rule breaking but
about accountability
and transparency at the heart of
government
laura bundock sky news